Hi zusammen! Heute gibt's ein Plätzchenrezept.
Und zwar Leute, ihr glaubt's nicht! - gestern Abend war ich am Laptop,
weil eigentlich war ein anderer Dreh geplant und dann saß ich wie gesagt am Laptop
so hier am Surfen und so und guck dann so hier in meine Word Dateien..
Und dann kommt mir doch tatsächlich meine Word Datei von vor 11 Monaten vor Gesicht!
Da hab ich mir nämlich - boah ich hab 2 Tage lang richtig viel gebacken
weil ich wollte unbedingt einen Plätzchenteig, in dem ich dann gaaanz viele verschiedene Plätzchen herausbekomme!
Insgesamt habe ich 6 verschiedene Varianten aus dem einen Plätzchenteig rausbekommen.
Ich hab mir für heute überlegt ich greife das Rezept auf und nehme dann allerdings nur 3 Rezepte.
Ich möchte das Video nämlich splitten damit's nicht so unendlich lang wird und ihr halt noch einen Überblick habt.
Dafür starten wir jetzt mit unserem Mürbeteig.
Ich nehme meine Küchenmaschine, ihr könnt euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Und anders als bei einem klassischen Mürbeteig ist bei meinem Rezept jetzt die Butter zimmerwarm.
Und die wird zusammen mit dem Zucker, ein bisschen Salz, Vanilleextrakt
in der Küchenmaschine für ca. 4min richtig schön hell-cremig gemixt.
So, anschließend die Geschwindigkeit runterfahren und nacheinander die Eier hinzu rühren, also wirklich nur ganz kurz.
Und danach kommt das ganze Mehl dazu.
So und jetzt haben wir einen Teig, der ist super geschmeidig.
Ich brauch den auch gar nicht mehr mit den Händen zu kneten.
Und dieser Teig muss jetzt kühlen.
Also wie gesagt: das ist jetzt kein typischer Mürbeteig, auch von der Konsistenz nicht.
Der ist super, super geschmeidig.
Ah Moment, das zeige ich dir gerne noch mal!
(H: *lacht* Ich wollt's mal zeigen!)
Ja, der ist so. Also der klebt auch nicht an den Händen.
Und da braucht ihr jetzt - entweder macht ihr das mit Frischhaltefolie
oder ihr nehmt euch Frischhaltedosen.
Übrigens: Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch natürlich unten in die Videobeschreibung
genauso wie alle Produkte, die ich benutze. Und was ich euch auch dazuschreibe:
Ich zähle gleich mal, wie viele Kekse ich dann tatsächlich rausbekommen habe von jeder Sorte.
Ich glaube das ist auch nochmal interessant. So, ein bisschen Mehl..
Und jetzt den Teig durch 3 teilen und dann in die Vorratsdosen legen,
Deckel drauf und dann für 1h in den Kühlschrank tun.
Also ich nehme mir jetzt Teig Nr.1 und das werden leckere Mandelplätzchen.
Dafür einfach den Teig jetzt aus der Frischhaltedose nehmen
und gemahlene Mandeln einkneten.
Und ihr könnt auch wenn ihr merkt, dass der Teig ein bisschen trocken wird,
könnt ihr immer wieder einen Schluck Milch dazugeben und einfach einkneten
und dann habt ihr schöne Mandelplätzchen!
So und jetzt den Teig einmal direkt auf dem Backpapier ausrollen.
Also 3-4mm Dicke finde ich persönlich am besten, das könnt ihr natürlich auch selber entscheiden.
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch entweder einen Teigroller, ein Messer
oder eben so einen gewellten Teigroller, den nehme ich jetzt.
Und dann einfach ganz wie ihr möchtet: ob ihr jetzt Quadrate macht oder Stifte
ist euch überlassen. Ich glaube, ich mach so längliche Streifen.
Ich hab den Keksteig jetzt auf dem Blech nochmal so ein bisschen auseinander gefriemelt
damit die nicht wieder ineinander zusammenwachsen und ihr keinen Riesen Cookie habt.
Und ich hab auch noch einen Tipp: Wenn ihr jetzt zu lange braucht und das Ganze sehr weich wird,
dann könnt ihr auch das ganze Blech nochmal für 10min in den Kühlschrank stellen
und direkt danach erst backen, dann verläuft euch das nämlich nicht mehr.
Und weil ich sie so zu langweilig fand, hab ich gedacht es müssen noch Mandeln obendrüber.
Da habe ich jetzt gehobelte Mandeln. Da gebe ich die einfach hier oben drüber.
Die könnt ihr auch so ein bisschen eindrücken.
Und dann kommen sie auch schon in den Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Da brauchen die je nach Dicke 6-8min. Also ich glaube meine da sie schon sehr dünn sind brauchen die nur 6min.
So, wer möchte - die sind jetzt hier auch schon abgekühlt -
kann hier auch noch ein bisschen Schokolade drauf geben, das mache ich jetzt mit meinem Spritzbeutel.
Ich hab jetzt grad schon mal probiert, die schmecken richtig gut! So richtig mürbe-zart...
So richtig..
(H: Lecker, ne?)
Richtig lecker!
(H: Schmeckt bestimmt richtig gut!)
Jaa, schmeckt sehr gut Hamza!
Mmh!
(H: Gut, du ärgerst die Leute gerade und zusätzlich auch noch mich!)
(H: Mich ärgerst du auch!)
Tschuldigung! Okay hier, darfst auch!
(H: Komm, ich nehm auch den kleinsten jetzt hier weg!)
(H: Mmmh!)
Geil, ne?
(H: Warum schmecken Kekse so geil?!)
Ja, frag ich mich auch grad! Normalerweise sind Kekse so: "Och, joa.."
(H: Langweilig halt, ne? Aber die sind richtig geil!)
Die sind heftig!
Weiter geht's mit Kekse Nr.2! Da machen wir die berühmten Engelsaugen
oder auch Husarenkrapfen genannt. Das Wort hört sich einfach nicht appetitlich an finde ich!
Aber sei's drum! Ich gebe hier jetzt einmal Backpapier aufs Backblech.
Das Gute übrigens an meinem Backblech ist, dass ihr die Bügel einfahren könnt
und so passt das auch locker in den Kühlschrank falls ihr wirklich mal zu lange braucht
und das Ganze einfach zu weich werden sollte.
So, jetzt schnappt ihr euch immer so ein bisschen was vom Teig,
rollt ihn zu Kugeln..
Hallo, nicht träumen! *lacht*
(H: Ich träum voll!)
Zu einer gewöhnlichen Kugeln rollen.. jetzt platziere ich ihn direkt hier auf meinem Blech.
Und dann schnappt ihr euch irgendwas,
Kochlöffelrückseite, irgendwas, womit ihr da so reindrücken könnt.
Und da kommt später dann unsere Marmelade rein.
Ich glaube traditionell kommt da Johannisbeermarmelade oder Joahnnisbeergelee rein.
Ich nehme jetzt Erdbeermarmelade , ihr könntet auch Himbeere nehmen.
Was ich mir auch gut vorstellen könnte ist z.B. Lemon Curd odeer...
(H: Haselnusscreme!)
Haselnusscreme!
Aber ich bin ganz ehrlich: Dadurch, dass sie erst in 2 Wochen bei uns im Lager eintrifft unsere Haselnusscreme,
habe ich die jetzt im heutigen Rezept nicht benutzt weil ich finde das wäre ein bisschen fies!
Ich packe die jetzt einmal in den Backofen, der ist ja noch warm.
180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für ca. 12min. Achtet darauf, dass sie nicht zu dunkel werden
und dann sehen wir uns jetzt direkt wieder zum dritten Rezept!
Teig Numero...Trii! *lacht* Numero 3!
Wir machen - da habe ich mir was Schönes überlegt, dass das so ein bisschen edler aussieht,
da machen wir Lebkuchen-Walnuss Plätzchen.
Dafür nehmen wir uns den Teig und kneten einfach Lebkuchengewürz ein.
Da braucht ihr auch nicht viel, der Geschmack ist schon echt stark!
Kurz, wirklich nur kurz einkneten
und dann rolle ich ihn auf der Arbeitsfläche aus.
Wer jetzt so eine Arbeitsfläche hat bei der der Teig immer klebt,
dann könnt ihr minimal so ein bisschen Mehl nehmen, das wär kein Problem!
Und dann einfach runde Kreise ausstechen und da nehme ich mir einfach so eine dicke große Spritztülle,
und ich gucke mal gleich, wie viel Durchmesser die hat. Ansonsten könnt ihr auch ein Glas oder sowas nehmen.
Also ein çay-Glas, ein Teeglas dann am besten!
(K: Das ist ein Fail, das ist ein Fail! *lacht*)
(H: Boah was hast du da gemacht, Kiki?)
(K: Die lieben sich!)
(H: Was für die lieben sich? Du hast den einfach zerstört!)
Meine Kekse haben einen Durchmesser von 3 ½cm
aber ihr müsst eigentlich nur darauf achten, dass die Walnuss drauf passt. Da hab ich nämlich so drauf geachtet.
Die soll halt später drauf kommen. Jetzt backen wir die Kekse bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
ich würde schon fast sagen nur 3min wenn überhaupt.
(H: Was?!)
Weißt du warum? Weil die sehr dünn sind, sehr klein sind, da kommt nichts oben drüber.
Die werden einfach so gebacken. Bleibt einfach vorm Backofen stehen!
Die müssen auf jeden Fall schön hell sein und nur von unten gebräunt sein.
Da machen immer viele den Fehler und gucken, dass es von oben braun ist
aber dann sind sie schon zu trocken!
Und danach vollständig abkühlen lassen und dann zeige ich wie's weiter geht. Bis gleich!
Meine Kekse haben 4min gebraucht! *lacht*
Aber manchmal brauchen sie auch 3, es kommt wirklich auf die Hitze im Ofen an.
180° C ist ja nicht immer 180° C!
So müssen sie sein. Also wirklich sehr hell noch von der Oberfläche
und - ist das noch im Fokus?
(H: Ja!)
Und hier wirklich maximal goldbraun.
Und jetzt machen wir folgendes:
Sie durften hier schon abkühlen, ich hab sie auch auf so ein Abkühlgitter gepackt
damit's einfach von unten nicht mehr nachbräunt.
(H: Und der Kaffee hier ist auch kalt!)
Och!
Man gönnt sich doch sonst nichts hier!
Also, ich hab mir auch ein bisschen Vollmilchkuvertüre geschmolzen überm Wasserbad.
Ihr könnt's auch in der Mikrowelle machen, dann aber bitte geringe Wattzahl nehmen, also 360°!
So, jetzt nehmen wir uns immer einen Keks,
tunken ihn da rein - hast du drauf?
Tunken ihn da rein, einmal schön ummanteln..
So, und dann aufs Backpapier.
Und dann nehmen wir uns ne hübsche Walnuss - die z.B. - und packen die da drauf.
(H: Das war's?)
Das war's!
Aber richtig lecker!
(H: M-hm!)
(H: Ich glaub mit Zartbitter kann man das auch ganz gut machen, oder?)
Genau, Zartbitter, weiße..geht alles!)
Also Leute, ich verabschiede euch schonmal aus dem Video, mach' hier noch fleißig weiter, trink mein Käffchen
und schreib euch wie gesagt alles ganz genau hier unten in die Videobeschreibung
und freue mich natürlich, wenn ihr mir einen Kommentar da lasst, z.B.
welches der 3 Rezepte euch am besten gefallen hat
und welches ihr auf jeden Fall nachmachen werdet.
Aber eigentlich ist ja logisch, dass ihr alle 3 nachmacht weil 1 Teig, 3 Plätzchen!
Vielleicht wollt ihr auch noch die anderen Rezepte sehen, die ich noch auf meinem Laptop gespeichert habe,
schreibt's mir dann gerne hier rein. Und dann würde ich mal sagen:
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüüss!
Hamza da kommt nichts mehr, ich bin fertig!
(H: Ich wollt aufnehmen wie du Kaffee trinkst nochmal!)
Achsoo, das zeige ich euch natürlich! Schön genüsslich hier!
Mmmmh!
(H: Ausm Strohhalm!)
Jaa! Das mach ich voll gerne übrigens, macht Spaß!
Und das verfärbt die Zähne auch nicht!
(H: Schlau, schlau!)